inondations. On se prépare,
comme nous le dit Melissa
François.
- Engagés dans une véritable
course contre la montre,
ces résidents préparent le plus
de sacs de sable que possible
afin de protéger leur propriété.
- It's time to go.
- Les quincailleries
ont été prises d'assaut.
Mais tout le monde n'a pas
le même empressement.
Ce couple s'est préparé au pire;
il attend Ian sur la plage.
- We're not too concerned
at all.
- Sa trajectoire préoccupe
les autorités.
Ian continue sa route vers
la côte ouest de la Floride
après avoir frappé Cuba.
Son passage dans les eaux
chaudes du golfe du Mexique
pourrait faire de lui
un ouragan majeur de catégorie 4
sur une échelle de 5.
Quelque 2,5 millions de
personnes ont reçu l'ordre
d'évacuer. C'est le cas
de Marie-Claude Tremblay.
MARIE-CLAUDE TREMBLAY,
résidente de Tampa
- Les choses qui nous sont
chères, que j'ai mises en
hauteur. Je prends ce que j'aime
le plus parce que je sais pas
si je vais revoir le restant
de mes vêtements,
de mes affaires, t'sais.
- Le gouverneur de Santis
a réitéré ce message à ceux qui
défient l'ordre d'évacuation.
Des abris sont mis en place,
quelque 5000 soldats de
la garde nationale de l'État
de Floride sont déployés.
Le mot d'ordre est la sécurité,
car les biens matériels se
remplacent, mais pas les vies.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.